[Música]
en las primeras horas del 13 de agosto
de 1961 trabajadores de alemania
oriental blanqueados por soldados y
policías comenzaron a rasgar las calles
sea erigir barreras en todo berlín y sus
alrededores
esta noche marcó el comienzo de uno de
los hitos más infames de la historia el
muro de berlín la construcción del muro
continuó en la siguiente década mientras
separaba familias cortaba barrios y
dividía no sólo alemania sino al mundo
para entender cómo llegamos a este punto
tenemos que volver a la segunda guerra
mundial eeuu gran bretaña y francia
unieron fuerzas con la unión soviética
contra las potencias del eje después de
derrotar a la alemania nazi cada una de
las naciones victoriosa se ocupó parte
del país la división iba a ser temporal
pero los antiguos aliados tenían
desacuerdos sobre sus visiones para la
europa de la posguerra las potencias
occidentales promovieron economías de
mercado liberales mientras que la unión
soviética trató de rodearse de naciones
comunistas obedientes incluyendo una
alemania debilitada a medida que sus
relaciones se deterioraban se formó la
república de alemania en el oeste y los
soviéticos crearon la república
democrática alemana en el este los
países satélites soviéticos
restringieron el comercio y el paso y se
forma una frontera prácticamente
intransitable se conoció como la cortina
de hierro en la antigua capital alemana
de berlín las cosas eran en sí muy
complicadas aunque la ciudad estaba
totalmente dentro del territorio de la
rda el acuerdo de posguerra otorgó a los
aliados la administración conjunta así
eeuu gran bretaña y francia- crearon un
enclave demócrata en los distritos
occidentales de berlín aunque
oficialmente se les prohibió a los
alemanes del este salir del país en
berlín era simplemente cuestión de
caminar o tomar un metro tranvía o
autobús a la mitad occidental y luego
viajar a alemania occidental o más allá
esta frontera abierta planteaba un
problema para los líderes de la rda
habían apostado por representar la
resistencia comunista contra hitler y
retrataron a la rf como una continuación
del régimen nazi mientras estados unidos
y sus aliados invirtieron dinero en la
reconstrucción de la rf la unión
soviética- extraía recursos del este
como reparaciones de guerra y su
economía planificada era aún menos
competitiva la vida en la rda estaba
bajo el ojo vigilante de la policía
secreta la stasi que con informantes y
espionaje teléfonico vigilaba a los
ciudadanos por cualquier indicio de
deslealtad si bien existía educación y
asistencia médica gratuita en el este y
el oeste se jactaba de más sueldos altos
bienes de consumo y libertad personal
para 1961 cerca de 35 millones casi el
20 por ciento de la población de la rda
se había ido entre ellos muchos jóvenes
profesionales para evitar más pérdidas
alemania oriental decidió cerrar la
frontera y así llegó el muro de berlín
extendiéndose por 43 kilómetros por
berlín y 112 a través de alemania
oriental la barrera inicial consistía en
malla asia alambre de púas algunos
berlineses escaparon saltando sobre el
alambre oa través de las ventanas pero
cuando la pared se expandió se hizo más
difícil para 1965 se habían añadido 106
kilómetros de hormigón de 36 metros de
altura cubierto con una tubería lisa
para evitar escaladas en los siguientes
años la barrera se reforzó con abrojos
perros guardianes e incluso minas
terrestres junto con 302 miradores y 20
bunkers una valla paralela se limitaba a
una zona de 100 metros llamada la franja
de muerte allí todos los edificios se
demolieron y el suelo se cubrió de arena
para dar una línea de visión clara para
los cientos de guardias con la orden de
disparar a cualquiera que intentara
cruzar sin embargo casi 5.000 personas
lograron huir de alemania oriental entre
1961 y 1989
algunos serán diplomáticos o atletas que
desertaron en el extranjero pero otros
serán ciudadanos comunes que cavaban
túneles nada van por canales volaban en
globos e incluso estrellaban un tanque
robado contra el muro sin embargo el
riesgo era grande más de 138 personas
murieron al tratar de escapar algunos
por disparos a plena vista de los
alemanes occidentales que no los podían
ayudar el muro estabilizó la economía de
la rda al retener su fuerza de trabajo
pero empañó su reputación convirtiéndose
en un símbolo global de la represión
comunista como parte de la
reconciliación con el este el tratado
fundamental de 1972 reconoció de manera
pragmática alemania oriental mientras
que alemania occidental conservo la
esperanza de la reunificación
aunque el régimen oriental permitió poco
a poco visitas familiares intento
desalentar el ejercicio de estos
derechos con un proceso burocrático
arduo y con tarifas altas sin embargo
estaba abrumado por las solicitudes a
finales de la década de 1980 la
liberalización de otros regímenes del
bloque oriental causo manifestaciones
masivas por libertad para viajar y
democracia en la tarde del 9 de
noviembre de 1989 la rda trató de calmar
la atención facilitando permisos de
viaje pero el anuncio trajo a miles de
berlineses orientales a los puntos de
cruce fronterizo del muro obligando a
los guardias sorprendidos a abrir las
puertas inmediatamente las multitudes se
regocijaron en berlin occidental
mientras la gente de ambos lados bailaba
sobre la pared y otros comenzaron a
demolerla con las herramientas que
tenían a mano aunque los guardias
fronterizos trataron inicialmente de
mantener el orden pronto quedó claro que
los años de división habían terminado
después de cuatro décadas oficialmente
alemania se reunificó en octubre de 1990
y la unión soviética cayó poco después
hoy en día algunas partes del muro
siguen en pie como recordatorio de que
cualquier obstáculo que impongamos para
impedir la libertad también lo podemos
romper
estás listo para seguir aprendiendo
suscríbete a nuestro canal para saciar
tu curiosidad
[Música]